[Woman]- Filet mignon
is a really wonderful
high quality piece of steak.
It's a bit pricier than other cuts,
so it can be a little intimidating.
But whether you're splurging
for a special occasion
or just honing in on your skills,
here's a few foolproof ways to make sure
you get it right and
get the most out of it.
(slow jazz electric guitar)
30 minutes before you start cooking
you want to take your
steak out of the fridge
and let it rest at room temperature.
If you grab it straight from the fridge
and throw a cold steak in a hot pan,
it'll bring down the pan's temperature
and you won't get that great crust.
Next you want to pat your
steak dry with paper towel.
This will absorb any excess moisture
that could keep the steak
from getting an even crust.
So, then you want to really
generously season the steak
with coarse salt and pepper.
This might seem like an
aggressive amount of seasoning
but you really need that much
to get the flavor throughout the steak.
And don't forget to cover every side.
Next, we're going to sear the steak.
For searing, you should
use a stainless steel
or cast iron pan,
because they're oven safe
and can maintain a high, steady heat
which you need to get
a really great crust.
Heat the pan over high heat
for about five minutes.
You can actually feel the heat
coming off the pan when it's ready.
Then we're going to add
a neutral oil with a high smoke point.
We use grapeseed oil,
but you could also use
canola, vegetable or even sunflower oil.
Once you see the oil start
to shimmer like this,
and it's starting to smoke,
that's when you know you're
ready to start searing.
Place the filet in the pan and let it sit
for two to three minutes
without moving it.
Seriously don't move it.
That's going to allow it to form
this really great crust,
also known as that maillard reaction.
After that crust is
formed, flip your steak.
If it's sticking to the pan,
that just means it's not ready yet,
and you should let it keep
searing until it self-releases.
If you really want to enhance
the flavor of your steak,
you can baste it.
To baste, you want to
add a couple tablespoons
of butter along with some
herbs and garlic to the pan.
Then you tilt the pan so the
butter pools on one side,
and continuously spoon that herby butter
over the steak for one to two minutes.
This process is a really quick step
to infuse your steak
with even more flavor.
Trust us, you should try it.
So, we're going to finish
our steak off in the oven
because it's the easiest way
to guarantee an even cook.
Place the pan in a pre-heated
oven of 450 degrees.
Seven minutes will get
you a perfectly done
medium rare filet, which
is what we'd recommend.
It should be 130 degrees when
you take it out of the oven.
After letting it rest, the
temperature will go up to 135.
If you prefer a different cook,
you can adjust the amount
of time in the oven.
We prefer medium rare because
well, your steak is going to stay
really tender and flavorful.
Then you want to let it rest
at room temperature for about ten minutes
to make sure it stays tender and juicy.
If you slice it right away,
the juices will run out,
which can dry out your steak.
When you let it rest the juices
will absorb evenly throughout the steak,
keeping it tender.
The temperature will continue to rise
by about five degrees while it's resting.
With any steak, you want to
slice it against the grain.
Filet Mignon is already a
really tender cut of steak,
but this is just an extra tip to make sure
it's the best it can be.
And that's all it takes!
Filet mignon is a really
wonderful cut of meat,
but it can be pretty intimidating
because of it's price point.
But when you want a
splurge, give it a try!
It's not fundamentally harder to cook
than any other cuts of steak,
the same principals apply.
And with these few tips in mind,
you're guaranteed to get a
restaurant-quality steak at home.
(slow jazz piano)
I mean you can make it for your spouse...
For yourself... I've made
it for myself many times.
If you're trying to woo someone.
[Other Woman]- It's a good woo
[Woman]- It's a good woo technique!
(laughs)
It's a good woo steak!
(camera shutter)